vietnam s'ouvrira demain le sommet des
pays francophones dans ce pays le
français n'est plus couramment parlée il
reste tout de même présent dans
certaines écoles et pas forcément pour
les plus favorisés pas forcément dans
les grandes villes
isabelle bechler tristan le bras c'est
sur les hauts plateaux du sud vietnam
que les colonisateurs français avait
introduit la culture du café et dans
cette province de bois de l'étroite
l'ethnie et des avait traditionnellement
les meilleurs rapports avec la france
car les hommes il travaillait dans les
plantations ou s'engager dans l'armée
française
mais dans quelques mots parce que parce
que il ya meilleure auto oubliée il ya
longtemps
les colons sont partis avec leurs armes
et leurs missionnaires
il reste le café une tradition du
français bien surprenante dans le monde
rural elle-même unifiée qui va des
usagers de dalat jusqu'à 75 e grimm
hansel il est français c'est d'élèves du
primaire de l'école de hand in depuis
trois ans moi c'est une des 29 classes
bilingues de la petite ville de one
network et le français eudeline il croit
beaucoup aux structures et l'esprit des
enfants
merci de raisonnement et puis par la
voir les choses arrivent aussi commun
est comme ça il faut déduire le coût des
sources à après la profitation coin fait
j'ai pas fini
montbron le petit longue à 8 ans on est
à 7 2 et manier de français tous les
soirs après la classe sa maman l'emmène
voir son grand père un ancien d'armes et
de françaises ou qu'il fasse ses devoirs
et améliore sa prononciation
le vieux monsieur croit dur comme fer
aux avantages du français et il dessine
un brillant avenir à son petit fils la
prochaine fois peut-être ai pas parlé il
ya des départs les ego mal à quoi vous
parlez leur de communication avec les
étrangers est de travailler dans le
gouvernement goy bonne mais toi tu as
soigneusement gardé des traces des
missionnaires français comme d'ailleurs
de sa lutte anticoloniale la petite
ville des hauts plateaux est tout aussi
fier de ces classes bilingues aux
français toutes considérées comme des
classes des lip le réseau d'enseignants
de français y est animé par une
pédagogue belge particulièrement motivés
l'objectif au vietnam c'est d'obtenir en
l'an 2000 5 % de bacheliers français et
cela lui ce oui je pense qu'on est bien
parti puisque c'est un ici est déjà fax
en cinq classes bilingues au vietnam a
avant paiement jean marc luco brothers
in arms les concours des cordes à son
d'un